[Musique]
c'est toujours de nuit que florian
commencent ou terminent sa journée au
conservatoire de tours
[Musique]
7h15 le matin avant d'aller au lycée
21h30 le soir ce jeune corniste de 14
ans a été révélé l'an dernier par
l'émission prodige sur france 2
aujourd'hui c'est la sortie d'un cd une
aventure extraordinaire mais pas de quoi
vu tourner la tête
c'était pas une fin en soi ce n'était
pas une ambition première mais mais
c'était un plus parce que ça permet
entre guillemets de me faire connaître
et de faire des concerts en soliste
quand on a quelqu'un comme florian
prodige alors après cd cd grand bon en
tout cas quelqu'un qui a énormément de
talent mais car beaucoup d'envié surtout
c'est ça que j'apprécie chez lui chez
tous ses copains aussi ont misé ont
l'ambition de vouloir être professionnel
plus tard donc le professionnel le
professionnalisme
ça commence par l'esprit quoi donc il
faut leur enseigner un petit peu le
béaba des choses à apprendre à apprendre
le temps et travailler plus dans
l'intelligence que dans la précipitation
les courses s'enchaînent en solo ou avec
l'ensemble des corps ils sont 5 1 ont
joué depuis trois ans conservatoire une
histoire d'amitié de travail acharné et
la salle de répétition est devenu leur
territoire généralement je prenne mon
instrument là au milieu de la pièce
mais ici généralement je travaille plus
mon travail sur partition j'analyse les
partitions tout ça tout ça là c'est
l'endroit où je rangerai partition je
range mes petites affaires tout ça là de
l'autre côté au tissu de là bas c'est le
coin paul au cjb
ce soir-là florio paul gibert et yahi
lucie répète pour une audition prodige
ou pas mais passionnés tous il rêve de
devenir professionnel une longue route
qui ne leur fait pas peur
il ya plein de gens très fort et ya
plein
et c'est des concours quoi donc même en
étant très fort on n'est pas sur des
prix donc il faut juste beau c'est
beaucoup et bien cancer enregistrement
tournée l'année 2019 s'annonce bien
remplie pour florian le bleiz qui
devrait aussi tenter le concours
d'entrée au conservatoire national de
paris